hemos pasado muchos vídeos hablando de
campos electrostáticos y la potencia en
una carga la energía potencial en una
carga etcétera pero veamos qué sucede
con una potencia dada cuando permitimos
que la carga se mueva y esto le será de
mucho interés ya que aprenderán cómo
funciona el mundo moderno digamos que
tengo una fuente de voltaje vamos a
dibujarlas más o menos por acá
esta es mi fuente de voltaje mejor
conocida como batería y aquí tenemos la
terminal positiva y aquí la terminal
negativa en otro vídeo me dedicaré a
explicar cómo funciona a detalle una
batería pero digamos que no importa
cuánta corriente o carga fluya de un
lado de la batería al otro lado de
alguna manera los voltajes permanecen
constantes esto es algo poco intuitivo
porque ya aprendimos sobre capacitores y
aprenderemos más sobre ellos en el
contexto de los circuitos pero cuando
aprendimos sobre capacitores si nos
deshacemos de la carga en un extremo
todo el voltaje a través del capacitor
se decremento pero en las baterías esto
es algo mágico creo que fueron
inventadas por volta y es por eso que
nombramos volts y voltaje y todo esto
pero esto es una cosa mágica que aunque
un lado pierda carga hacia el otro lado
el voltaje o el potencial entre ambos
lados permanece constante y esta es la
magia de la batería asumimos que tenemos
uno de estos instrumentos mágicos y
ustedes probablemente tendrán alguno en
sus calculadoras o teléfonos y veamos
qué sucede cuando permitimos que la
carga viaje de un lado al otro digamos
que tengo un material conductor perfecto
este material conductor por acá
este objeto que hoy te voy a explicar
qué es
bajamos a
y aquí está que dibujaba aquí en el
proceso de comenzar a conectar la
terminal positiva con la terminal
negativa de la batería los estoy
exponiendo a la notación esquemática de
la ingeniería eléctrica así que qué es
esto bueno estas líneas de aquí son
cables y asumimos que estos cables son
conductores ideales y que la carga puede
viajar libremente a través de ellos sin
encontrar impedimento alguno
esta cosa de aquí arriba esa línea
quebrada es una resistencia o resistor y
eso es algo que impedirá el
desplazamiento de la carga y evitará que
viaje tan rápido como pueda y de este
otro lado tendremos el cable otro pedazo
de cable conductor ideal
ahora en qué sentido va a viajar la
corriente voy
creo que ya he mencionado esto antes
pero en los circuitos electrónicos son
los electrones los que viajan los
electrones son las partículas
subatómicas que giran con gran velocidad
alrededor del núcleo del átomo y el
hecho de que estos electrones se pueden
mover es lo que permite que fluyen a
través de un conductor así que el
movimiento del objeto si consideramos
como objeto a un electrón que tiene una
masa muy muy muy pequeña se da desde la
terminal negativa hacia la terminal
positiva recordamos que los opuestos se
atraen pero las personas que
originalmente quedaron en estos esquemas
electrónicos los pioneros en ingeniería
eléctrica y electricistas etcétera ellos
decidieron que es la corriente fluye de
la terminal positiva a la negativa no sé
quizá lo hicieron solamente para
confundir al resto del mundo
así que en general el flujo de corriente
se expresa en este sentido y la
corriente se expresa con la letra y
mayúscula y que es la corriente
antes de que les hable acerca de la
corriente aunque es muy común que la
gente y los libros de texto digan que la
corriente fluye del lado positivo al
lado negativo el flujo real de las cosas
ocurre del lado o terminal negativa a la
terminal positiva pues no es que estos
protones y pesados neutrones se muevan
por el circuito cuando se compara el
tamaño de un protón con el de un
electrón nos damos cuenta de que sería
una locura esto son los electrones estas
partículas pequeñas y súper rápidas que
se mueven a través del conductor desde
la terminal negativa hacia la positiva
así que pueden ver esta corriente como
la falta o la ausencia de electrones
pero bueno no quiero confundirlos
simplemente recuerden que esta es la
convención pero la realidad es hasta
cierto punto lo opuesto a esta
convención
bueno y qué es esta resistencia
conforme fluye la corriente y aquí
quiero mantenerme lo más apegada a la
realidad para que visualicen bien qué es
lo que está sucediendo
conforme fluyen los electrones que bueno
recordamos los electrones se encuentran
aquí en esta terminal vamos a ponerlos
de otro color estos electrones verdes se
encuentran aquí en la terminal negativa
y conforme empiezan a fluir por el
conductor si por alguna razón vamos a
asumir que este cable es tan asombroso
que los electrones nunca se tapan con
los átomos de este alambre
van a estar fluyendo por acá estos
electrones se me fueron ahora sí que se
alejaron del medio
vamos a quitar a los que se escapan
cuando estos electrones que van por acá
llegan a esta resistencia o este
resistor
es cuando estos electrones comienzan a
toparse o a tropezarse con ciertas cosas
con los otros electrones que están en
este material este de acá
así que estos electrones van a comenzar
a toparse con cosas que como
consecuencia van a hacer que disminuyan
su velocidad ya que se van a estar
tropezando con cosas que los estorban y
mientras más cosas haya o se reduzca más
el espacio pues los electrones van a
disminuir más su velocidad más adelante
veremos que mientras más larga sea esta
resistencia más oportunidad habrá de que
los electrones tropiecen con otras cosas
y esto le llamamos resistencia o
resistor
resistencia
y su labor es dictar qué tan rápido
fluye la corriente
la corriente es simplemente el flujo de
la carga por segundo vamos a escribirlo
la corriente
es igual a el cambio de la carga
el cambio de la carga entre un segundo o
el cambio en el tiempo diferencia del
tiempo
ustedes pueden imaginarse esto como que
el voltaje representa cuántas ganas
tiene esta corriente de fluir si hay una
gran diferencia de voltaje entre estas
dos terminales todos los electrones que
se encuentran aquí tendrán muchísimas
ganas de salir por acá y llegar a la
terminal positiva y si hay mayor voltaje
las ganas que tendrán estos electrones
de salir serán todavía mayores antes de
que la gente comprendiera la diferencia
de voltaje la gente se refería a este
deseo entre comillas de los electrones
de viajar de aquí a acá como la fuerza
de la motivación del electrón pero ya
aprendimos que esto no es una fuerza es
simplemente esta diferencia de potencial
que podemos ver como una presión
eléctrica la gente suele referirse al
voltaje como una presión eléctrica
una vez que les proporcionamos a los
electrones una ruta para ir de aquí a
que a través del circuito los electrones
comenzarán a viajar y asumimos que este
cable no proporciona resistencia por lo
que los electrones pueden viajar tan
rápido como quiera pero al llegar a la
resistencia comenzarán a tropezarse con
cosas por lo que esto limita qué tan
rápido puede viajar un electrón si
ustedes se imaginan que si este objeto
de aquí es el factor que determina que
tan rápido puede viajar los electrones
no importa qué tan rápido puedan viajar
estos la resistencia va a actuar como un
cuello de botella ya que viajan muy
rápido para que se detienen al llegar
aquí y ya que saben esta parte pueden
viajar rápido nuevamente los electrones
de acá no pueden viajar más rápido de lo
que marca la resistencia por qué ocurre
esto
porque imagínense los electrones que
aquí van más lento comiencen a
acumularse aquí antes de entrar a la
resistencia tendríamos un aumento de
corriente justo antes de la resistencia
al acumularse los electrones que tienen
que esperar para pasar por ella pero
esto no es el caso todos los electrones
viajan con la misma tasa en todo el
circuito me pegó mucho la realidad
aunque esté ignorando la convención que
indica que la corriente va de la
terminal positiva a la terminal negativa
porque me interesa que comprendan muy
bien qué es lo que está ocurriendo aquí
en la realidad
entonces nosotros sabemos y eso se llama
la ley de ohm sabemos que la corriente
es proporcional al voltaje a través del
circuito o también que el voltaje es
proporcional a la corriente vamos a
escribir esta ley voltaje es igual a
r que es el valor de la resistencia por
la corriente une mónico que aprendí hace
mucho tiempo para acordarse de esta
ecuación es victoria es la reina de
inglaterra con esta frase nos acordamos
que ve igual a r por i
y esto se va a cumplir esta ley de ohm
ley d hont
se va a cumplir siempre que se tenga una
temperatura constante
veremos esto con más detalle más
adelante ya que si se incrementa la
temperatura de la resistencia
sus partículas y moléculas se moverán
más y los electrones encontrarán más
cosas con las que tropezarse por lo que
la resistencia va a aumentar con
respecto al aumento de la temperatura
entonces la ley de aún también la puedo
escribir de manera que el voltaje es
igual a la resistencia por la corriente
o puedo poner que la corriente es igual
al voltaje entre la resistencia son dos
formas de expresar la misma ley también
veremos más adelante que diferentes
materiales tienen diferentes valores de
resistencias pero para cierto material a
cierta temperatura y con cierta
configuración el voltaje a través de una
resistencia o dividido entre esa
resistencia será igual a la corriente
del circuito la resistencia de un
registro o resistencia se mide en homs y
se expresa con la letra griega omega
ahora hagamos un ejemplo sencillo
digamos que esta es una batería de 16
voltios o volts
16 voltios por lo que la diferencia de
potencial de aquí es de 16 voltios entre
las terminales positivas y negativas
digamos que esta resistencia o resistor
es de 8 11 8 ohms cuál va a ser la
corriente que fluye por ese circuito
la convención y mostremos el sentido de
la corriente de izquierda a derecha
el resultado es bastante directo si
tenemos que el voltaje es igual a la
resistencia por la corriente y
sustituimos que el voltaje son 16
voltios
y que la resistencia es de 811 y tenemos
aquí nuestra incógnita que es la
corriente podemos despejar y nos va a
quedar que la corriente es igual a 16
volts entre 8 oms que es lo mismo a 2
amperes o amperios que son las unidades
de corriente pero como sabemos la
corriente es carga entre tiempo por lo
que estos 2 ams son iguales a dos culos
entre segundo me he pasado del tiempo lo
dejamos aquí donde ya vieron lo básico
de la ley de ohm y quizás ya tienen algo
de entendimiento de lo que ocurre en un
circuito y nos veremos en el siguiente
vídeo